stuff but but i'd like to tell you about
my future
if i may what's your future about so i'm
going to let people know that when is
bobby lee
going to go out and do the road and i
have
made a decision i am going to start
going on the road in september
nice and i'm tired of [ __ ] you pieces
of good people out there
you people you hold on out there
you see i shifted yeah yeah people are
good people [ __ ] good people
people out there all right accent too
are saying you know i've i've read some
comments bobby lee's afraid
he let the he let the coronavirus you
know instill fear in him
because he won't go out you know um
there's a lot of things
that i have a lot of character defects i
really do um
kaleido knows about him it's in her face
every step of the way
i receive it i accept it i can i will
yeah i you know there's a lot of
frailties i have but
you know i have performed in front of
20 000 people before and gotten booed
off stage
and then chose to do the same show the
next night
all right if you call that fear you can
call that fear
but i do have fears in my life but i've
always gone out
and i've tried to live my life to the
best of my ability and to walk through
very scary situations and i've done that
in my life i know that for a fact
i was petrified when i was 28 years old
29 years old when i
was asked to do jay leno i did stand up
on january what did you wear
and how i wore brown um dickies who
chose it
i did i had no money so i i just had i
used to wear
brown dickies skate shoes and a black
thermal shirt right so i kind of look
like
who went with you that day my brother
steve my manager and my agent who are
still my managing agents
and i remember being behind the curtain
and i remember jay
saying beforehand he goes well um don't
worry about it only 16 million people
are gonna watch
and go oh yeah oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
and i remember behind being behind that
curtain and
hearing jay go saw this next comic come
to the stage
um hold up it's his first national you
know his first
national television appearance uh he's
he
he performs it though he's a regular at
the comedy story here in hollywood
california
bobby lee and i remember walking
so scared you don't you don't know what
that's like people it's your
all the moisture from your mouth is gone
did they give you only one shot
you get one shot there's no there's no
do-over
really there's no do-over you do what
you do
i thought it was edited yeah i thought
that too oh really have you done it [ __ ]
face
yeah i did craig ferguson i did okay oh
you did dude craig
oh i missed that guy i did too
so you know there's no do-over and your
your mouth is dry
and you go out there and you see the
first thing you see
is the lights right then you see
then the next thing you see is the
audience
and then the third thing you see which
is the most petrifying is the cameras
because you have like four or five
cameras like you know
and then you're highly aware that jay
leno
and i think was um christina ricci was
the guest
before me so they're sitting sitting
there
just you know and i remember going to
the mic holding the mic
going uh oh that's not a good thought
but that's the first thing that ended in
my mind oh oh
and then just having this overwhelm
overwhelming feeling of adrenaline and
going you know what you're doing your
life depends on this
this is you know you know in every one
people's lives
you have moments where you have to
deliver
you have moments where you know
instinctually
that you have to hit the ball
because you get one chance and at that
time i had no money i had no future
i barely was with the agency that i was
with i had no money and i had to do it
all right so if you're saying that bobby
lee is living in fear go [ __ ] yourself
i'm sorry for saying it like that way
and you're good you guys are
pieces of good human beings i want to
take a second come out to the shows
come on to the show but that's not the
point the reason why
i don't go out and stuff isn't
necessarily will i beat the virus or
or whatnot is i'm just trying to be
mindful about other people
because i know this if my mom got it
she's dead
my mom's 80 years old you know she's
held this
moderately good for her age but she's an
old lady she could die
she's 80. yeah she looks young
thank you my point is is that it's not
for me
it's not for it's f you know i don't
want you know my fans to go out to my
shows early on
who have um a physical condition that
i'm not aware of
and they get the code covid at my show
you know so i'm just trying to be
mindful about that kind of stuff but so
i've made a decision i'm going to go in
september
because i'm not afraid i want i need to
go out there i want to see everybody
yeah and um now my survey has nothing to
do with what you just said
it has something to do with the one you
talked about later now i don't want to
take my survey
what's the survey do the survey
when you're speaking to someone or let's
say you're in a position where
you're you're speaking publicly or to a
friend or to a group of people
and then you have a frog in your throat
like a little bubble and your voice